hit me with the one-two-three and we're
gonna do it why I just wanted to sound
right wanted to look good that's it and
I want everybody to be able to enjoy it
the way it's supposed to be enjoyed I'm
passionate about everything that I do
you know I've been working for 20 years
this guy says no to everything we took
two years these headphones would not be
out ever if they weren't the best
sounding headphones there are and why
mean by best sounding headphones you
have to feel the music no matter what
music you're hearing and a lot of these
headphones are created by audio files
that don't not that audio files a bad
thing but they're their consciousness is
not to make the music to Bend with the
music is to just say okay this is what
it just sound like here is what it looks
like beats about what it feels like and
fashion but it looks like not on some
graph and what musics but you can't hear
music looking at something and no heard
music the way we did is commitment to
sound was like ours and I knew I said
you know what I got dr. Dre and I know
dr. Dre as well as anybody in the
entertainment business and I know I said
I got to put him with a crew that's
gonna have the patience to make these
things sound the way he hears music and
that ain't easy because these suckers
would have never come out if we had
gotten some gigantic corporation these
suckers would have never come out I mean
so dream come true for me I mean I've
been approached by almost every
audio-visual company that's that's out
there after Dre did it I'm not a follow
on my leader sound wise nobody has a
record
better than Dre nobody produces a record
sound wise better than Dre and to get a
chance to partner with him on what I do
with fashion and also add a little bit
to what I do a sound on how I hear sound
it was it was just something that I felt
was what would be historical they looked
the best and they sound the best and
that he was able to go and translate the
way I hear things and almost them then
show me how you know kit can sound like
this so when I listen to the Benjamins I
listened to the biggie life after death
down through these I heard things I've
never even heard before you know saying
it's another level of detail it's
another level of clarity articulation
that only he knows how to bring to the
table along with Monster together we try
to get the best sound quality you can
and something this small you know what I
mean it was hard enough trying to get
that Studio Headphones to have enough
base in them but you know finally
figured out a way to do it after two
years of working on it
you know it's much harder than making a
record okay right now that's why they
call it hardware it's hard